Translator: Andrea McDonough
Reviewer: Bedirhan Cinar
Dear subscribers,
there are over 250,000 of you now,
a critical mass
at a critical time.
We have the cumulative potential
to impact global education.
I've been assembled and given a voice for this video
to describe one way to do just that.
Please allow me 2.5 minutes to explain.
My name is TED-Ed
and I am a symbol for both the TED-Ed website
and the billions of videos available to you for free
on the website known as "YouTube".
Today I invite you on a journey
on which you will learn how to use
ed.ted.com to create a lesson
around the vast majority of videos on the web.
When I say, "create a lesson,"
I mean that you may use the TED-Ed website
to search for any video on YouTube.
Once you find the perfect video,
the one that really blows your hair back,
helps you understand,
or that makes you pause and say,
"My goodness, the universe is a fascinating place!",
you may use TED-Ed to enhance that video.
You might use the "Let's Begin" section
to set context for interpreting the video
or to define a learning objective for your students.
Or, you might use the "Think" section
to add multiple choice questions
with time-coded video hints
or open answer questions
that beg for thought-provoking, written responses.
Or, perhaps you'll use the "Dig Deeper" section
to expand upon the video with articles,
references,
or links to an application,
or maybe even your blog.
If any feature is not your cup of tea,
just click "Exclude".
And this new feature, "Discuss,"
it lets you create riveting discussions
around your favorite bits.
Learners, you can engage with lessons independently.
The site will save your answers, notes, and ideas
to your personal profile
and track your learning over time.
New lessons are added every day.
Teachers, as you build or distribute customized lessons
to individuals or to groups,
you may use the site to track the progress
of single students or your entire class.
And no matter who you are,
if you take the time to create a particularly stunning lesson,
please also take the time to nominate it.
We will systematically feature
the best community-made lessons
within the ever-growing TED-Ed library,
free for the world to learn from,
to customize and to share.
The possibilities of this tool
are as infinite as YouTube itself.
And, we will be adding new features regularly
in the months and years to come.
To join me and many others
in building a library of lessons worth sharing,
simply click on one of the features that interests you.
Thank you for your time.